just wow is what we have to say about
that game Magness what will you say yeah
um I don't know it seemed at some point
we were both playing for for a win there
uh I mean of course a lot of things
happened before that but we were both
playing for a win then he was start
playing me at some point I was down to
seconds and then I don't know I don't
know what happened but uh I mean at some
point I started pushing my pawns I even
lost my queen but um somehow I managed
to to win I have no idea what is the
secret there to to stay I guess calm
when you lose your queen there and
eventually
win I don't know uh
I at least I had a clear plan which was
to push my pawns
and but it was um yeah it was a mess
what what was the emotions there in the
final
minutes
um I don't know I mean at Dan it was
just disbelief cuz um he was about to
put his King on the right square and
then you put it on the wrong square and
lost on the spot so was bit bit
surprising it's how good is it to win a
fight like this no no of course it feels
great so um and for the match it's it's
huge heart rate at the end there what
was
it I don't know mine is usually not that
high but I would guess higher than usual
probably congrats and good luck at next
one thank you wow yeah just wow you guys
got what a fight between them in the
first game back to you guys